Oh,
one to
refresh your memory about what we talked about last time,
um,
about the kindness of strangers last time we spent a lot of time talking about
kindness of strangers and in many ways,
um,
as this as an instance of Faulkner updating a long tradition of thinking about
hospitality.
Um,
and also thinking about pregnancy,
uh,
outside of wedlock or even with when you are in a marriage that the father is
not,
the thought is not your husband.
Um,
so leader updating,
Lina,
updating leader
from the Greek classics.
Um,
but also thinking about community and thinking about Lenas relation to the
southern community as an updating southern hospitality as an updating of the
ancient,
uh,
Greek ideal of hospitality to strangers.
So do,
they will be,
um,
thinking more about that,
but introducing a new term,
um,
and bring Christianity into play.
As you guys probably know that as Christians is very important in lighting
artists,
um,
and especially the Christian concept of how we should condemn ourselves towards
our neighbors.
Right?
So we'll be thinking about that and the various permutations of their Christian
idea of treat your neighbor as day stuff.
Um,
and,
but before we go into there that,
just want to talk a little bit about the narrative structure of a lady in Argos.
Obviously a leaner is one very important have of the narrative.
Uh,
she represents the undramatic have,
it's a narrative,
very peaceful,
very monotonous dealing where your drama can come into a part of the story is
when a supporting cast tick all there and the upstage her and become the
protagonist for,
there's just that short period of time.
Um,
so the undramatic narrative,
um,
revolving around Lina and those people where she comes into contact with.
And then opposite to that,
um,
is a very dramatic structure actually.
And we're beginning to see that,
uh,
in the reference to do any burden and the house being burned down and the
spectators.
And it will be good to have some human fat me to,
uh,
to,
to quicken the fire.
So I'm very,
very dramatic development and various other,
uh,
characters has to contribute to that dramatic narrative.
So we'll be looking at Joanna burden,
uh,
reverend hightower and obviously Joel Christmas.
Um,
so,
but,
um,
I just want to start by going back and looking squarely at this engine engine,
from the vinegars,
um,
which is probably the,
you know,
one of the central tenants of Christianity.
Um,
and we should take it not just the last line,
which is the land that all of us know,
but take it in its full context.
Um,
you should not use,
shall not take vengeance or bear a grudge against the sons of young people,
but usually love your neighbor as yourself.
I am the board,
so I'm loving your neighbor is in the context of Europe obeying God,
right?
So that is the,
that is,
it is under the rubric of your devotion to God,
your obedience to God,
um,
that you should love your neighbor.
But it's further,
um,
thicken by the notion that you should not take vengeance against others.
We might not necessarily,
um,
thing of the prohibition against vendors that we don't really associate
Christianity with the prohibitation against vengeance.
Um,
there's just no prohibition,
um,
in our current against vendors and our current legal and ethical thinking.
Um,
that period of justice is an instance where actually collected vendors.
So it is institutionalized.
There's no prohibition against vengeance,
but actually within,
at least in the videos,
there's a prohibition against vengeance.
So with the thing about what that means,
um,
and,
and putting that also under the rubric of loving your neighbor.
So all of this,
um,
is um,
very important to like the in August.
But I want to further introduce one other consideration,
which is a relatively new book that came up by three very important,
um,
thinkers and philosophers as love as Usia.
Um,
Eric Center Standard and um,
run kind of ran home,
call the neighbor,
the three of them.
Um,
each had an essay in this book called the neighbor.
and the org is really thinking about what the concept of neighbor could mean
after the Holocaust and after the numerous instances of genocide with witness in
the 20th century and the 20th first century,
it seems that the whole human propensity is to turn against those amount whom
you've lived all your life.
It takes such a short space of time,
you know,
generation,
some people might been living together in the same place.
All of a sudden you're turn against the person next door to you.
So,
um,
the three philosophers thing of this as a case of political theology,
it's a very interesting concept.
Um,
is thinking about the ethics of social conduct and behavior towards people who
are not kin to you,
um,
who have no blood ties to you.
Um,
you have no obligation other than just the obligation of treating them as
neighbors and what the appropriate conduct would be,
where the,
the limits,
um,
to be in someone's neighbors and what are the licenses that you can take.
Um,
so I'm very,
you know,
I would encourage you to just to take a look at this book,
um,
if you just want to do some reading and philosophy.
Um,
but I now let's go back to what we've been talking about a little bit last time
and just want to remind you of this,
um,
discussion,
this conversation that comes right at the heels of thinking about Brian
[inaudible] been in love.
It's the big fire in other side.
What can I be?
I don't remember anything out that way big enough to make all that smoke except
that burden.
How is maybe that's what it is.
And the other side,
my pepe says he can't remember how 50 years ago folks said it ought to be burned
with a low human fat meat to start a good,
maybe your pappy slipped up there instead of the five the site.
They all laughs.
Um,
so this is the other phase of the community.
Uh,
with going along with Lena,
we have this idea that human beings are just all kindness and that's all there
is.
But you know,
we sort of just know from experience that that's probably just half the story.
Um,
so Faulkner is very emphatic about showing us the other phase of the neighbor of
um,
and um,
and there's a genealogy to the burden house in Kipling's poem.
Um,
the white man's burden,
um,
that people who do good or consider themselves to do good quite often actually
incur.
Uh,
the resentment of those they do,
could do is interesting kind of psychological dynamics that take up the white
man's burden and re Pisco reward the blame of those leave better.
The hate of those you got.
Um,
I think that they actually is quite a natural human tendency not to want to be,
you know,
to have to get other people,
um,
taking care of you,
uh,
or in this particular way of doing good to you.
Um,
and so resentment essentially kind of a natural reaction and what the white
man's burden means.
Uh,
especially in the context of doing good two different race and obviously that
issue.
It was front and center,
uh,
drain reconstruction,
when you have artists lays becoming Freeman and what to do and how to educate
them and induct them really into citizenship.
Um,
so the lots of northern reformers when south,
um,
and a lot of them including Joanna burdens family had the idea that they would
be a fair too.
There will be their social reformers and we'll be educating the ex slaves.
Um,
but they also went by a different name in American history and that is the name
of the carpet bagger.
And we can see a very vivid illustration of that.
Um,
the huge back that is more than the panties really is the defining feature of
this person.
Um,
and there were mainly really contusions,
um,
about how much they will resent it in a pill spell itself.
So this one image of how doing good the claim to do good can actually benefit
yourself.
Likewise,
the self groaning under the burden of the cover back goats actual burden right
there.
Um,
and I'm not entirely clear about the logic of this regard.
Should just try it out and email,
you know,
email or just write a blog about this email if you can figure it out that you've
set logic anyway.
I mean,
there's excitement there,
but it's complicated.
Um,
so,
um,
cartoons,
political cartoons can be really a great way to think about,
um,
you know,
just pull it the goal history and social history and certainly a very important
background to light in August.
Um,
but what we now see is the outcome of their joy.
And their burden is,
we know is still there as the doer.
Someone who was doing good.
She is on the board of multiple charities.
She gives them money.
Um,
she has a black lawyer,
basically,
she spent her whole life,
um,
doing racial uplift,
working towards the welfare of the black population.
Um,
and this is what happens to her,
uh,
at the end of that live.
Um,
but the way those partners telling the story is actually the tone of that is
very different from the tone.
The just,
she was lying on the floor.
Her head had been cut.
[inaudible] this is,
um,
as is the custom and light in August.
Um,
but very dramatic episode is ran.
The tours is retold who us by someone who was there but not a central player in
the story.
So this whole discovery of Joanna burdens,
um,
Barney was reported by baron bunch to hightower and Byron wasn't there to do the
discovery either.
He was reporting when a country man who's a total stranger and coming to town in
a wagon with a total stranger.
Um,
being given this important functions with discovering Joanna burdens body.
So this is this country man from nowhere,
um,
telling just to,
I'm telling you about the event.
She was lying on the floor.
Her head had been cut pretty near of a lady with the beginning of gray hair,
the Madison,
how he stood there and he could hear the fire and there was smoke in the room
itself now like it had done a followed him in and how he was afraid to try the
pick up and carry her out because her head,
my come clean off.
So he ran back into the house and up the stairs again and into the room and Joe
of the cover off the bed and grow her onto it like a sack of meal.
And he said that what he was scared happened because the cover fell open as she
was laying on the side facing one way and her head was turned Korean around.
Like she was looking behind her and he said that if she could have just done
that when she was alive,
she might not have been doing it now.
Okay.
Thought there's actually repeating himself.
Right?
It's the same kind of construction that Lina use when she talks about herself
climbing out of the window for the last time.
It was a little difficult that time,
but if it had been that difficult from the first time,
she might not need to be doing it now.
Right?
So it's exactly the same structure,
um,
where there's where,
is that even in Linda's case,
even though you know,
it could have been seen as totally unfunny story is told in a funny way.
Um,
and this episode is,
it's really hard to see how it could be funny in any fashion except for the
weight.
Faulkner has chosen to tell the story.
So this is something very deep in Faulkner,
um,
that his temptation,
his compulsion is to tell a tragic story from a karmic point of view.
And we can speculate about why this is such a pattern in him.
Um,
but I think that he really doesn't want to give tragedy,
um,
the entirety of the field.
You know,
if we can think of the narrative feel,
um,
as either full occupancy or have occupancy,
tragedy is granted no more than half occupancy of the narrative feel at any
given moment.
Um,
and maybe it's not even half,
maybe it's here,
it seems to be less than half.
Um,
so here's the hundred million,
you know,
worrying about all the things that one really shouldn't be worrying about when
was discovering a dead body.
Um,
and the,
the can very contrived plot detail that too,
and his birth and his head is turned around.
So as she's looking back with,
and it's one of those,
turns out that there's actually a very,
um,
vulnerable,
uh,
genealogy to that particular configuration of that human body or human health in
relation to the rest of the body.
It turns out that the epic is coming into play as well because,
um,
in a divine comedy Canto,
Tony is very famous episode of,
um,
Dante and Virgil,
I'm going to hell and you know,
seeing all these people and how,
uh,
being punished and Don Hayes way your punishment is by the logic of Contra Paso
that the punishment is the repetition of your crime.
So this is what he sees.
Um,
the whole group people that has turned around as I inclined,
my head's still more.
I saw that each amazingly appear contorted between the Chin and where the chest
begins.
They had the faces twisted to what the hunches and found it necessary to walk
with because they could not see ahead of them.
And um,
this is an illustration.
Um,
Flaxman illustration of the all these people in health care has turned
backwards.
And the reason that they upon urge in this particular way,
um,
is that in life there was soothsayers they claim to foreseeing the future.
And of course in Dante is Cosmo's this very quite severe Christian Cosmo's,
uh,
like the,
the,
the Greek tradition.
Human beings are not really supposed to know anything about the future for
knowledge is now the privilege that human beings can claim.
So as a consequence of claiming for knowledge for the future,
these people were punished.
And how by having the has turned back was,
um,
and we can also think of Faulkner in many ways.
Thinking of this as a fifth punishment for social reformers,
social reformers also claimed to have some kind of privilege relation to the
future and they're reforming the present,
you know,
quite often,
uh,
because they have this vision about the future that they want the president to
approximate the vision of the future that they can sleep.
So,
um,
maybe that is the connection between Joanna and these ancient soothsayers.
Um,
but the,
the,
so there's the kind of a thematic connection,
but the tonal connection is,
is,
is different.
Um,
if we think about Dante based,
um,
incident,
in a divine comedy,
um,
there's just,
there's no humor in it is a terrible sight to see all the table with a has
turned back was,
and likewise in this representation,
there's nothing funny about this.
It could have been done in the funny fashion,
but it's never done in a funny fashion.
Whereas Faulkner's representation of Joe and there's definitely comic.
Um,
so it seems that every time,
anytime Faulkner in books,
uh,
kind of,
an analogy from a prior tax is always rewriting the tabs and changing,
especially the tone of that episode.
Um,
but so from Joanna or we get kind of complicated picture,
um,
of the malice of neighbors,
well I mean actually she's not killed by her neighbors as well find out.
So even though the neighbors are kind of rejoicing and having a lot of fun over
the fact that she's killed the houses burning down,
um,
even though they are enjoying it,
they actually not the instruments for her killing.
So that's important to remember.
Um,
and also that Faulkner for some reason chooses to approach it from a very odd
angle so that it's not exactly sympathy there thought leader is trying to
generate from the reader.
We can try that.
We should ask,
you know,
what kind of reader's response responses he's,
he's,
he,
he's cultivating in that particular episode,
but it's definitely now sympathy for Joanna.
Um,
so that puts us in a very peculiar relation as well because in some sense we are
the neighbors to Joanna,
right.
We are just like those neighbors who have some fun at her expands with the
readers are also having some fun at the expense.
So that is the,
the,
the kind of narrative that fault is,
is giving us,
um,
but to move on to the next figure who also,
and that's a kind of dance,
a permutation of the various meanings of neighbor.
And this was an actually,
it's given more space in terms of this full development of the various
incarnations of the concept of neighbor.
Um,
so this is the reference hightower who,
um,
came to town and then all of a sudden he loses his,
his,
um,
he loses his job as a minister.
Um,
and um,
then rumors not going around and about his relation with blacks as well.
Um,
and this is what happens to him one night because that evening,
some man not matched,
either tilt the knee room and this is the cook took the Negro man how and
Winton.
And when hired how wake the next morning he studied window was broken and on the
floor lay a break with no tie to it,
commanding him to get out of town by sunset inside of the KKK.
And he did not go.
And on the second morning a man found him in the woods about a mile from town.
He had been tie to a tree and beaten unconscious.
So this is exactly the same people,
the same people who,
um,
were kind to,
uh,
Lina public.
We're on Clensman.
Um,
you know,
it quite a common,
um,
is,
is it has a very deep roots actually in some southern communities.
Um,
and lots of were class when that you might not think would be plans when new
studies also have shown that actually lots of women were Klansmen that as well.
Um,
so,
um,
we,
we just don't know who,
uh,
within,
in this case was just the man.
But what is interesting,
they actually,
two interesting facts,
um,
about this one is that the man,
I'm not mass.
I think that that says a lot that actually,
um,
in,
in any kind of clan action,
um,
the people would the hood,
so you don't actually see the faces,
but these,
this variation on that,
this man are not who did,
they're not mass.
So that's very fun.
They are revealing the identity fully to hightower.
Um,
and then the other detail is that obviously they want hide how to leave town and
he does not go,
even though his billing unconscious,
he still refuses to leave.
So these two are the very important variation to the customer's story about Klan
violence.
And we'll see what comes from that that follows both giving us a kind of very
recognizable southern history,
um,
but also is giving us a very important variation on that southern history.
So let's look at fault.
Follow the calendar.
Permutation of the mallows are strangers.
He refused to tell who had done it.
The town knew that that was wrong and some of the men came to him and try again
to persuade him to leave Jefferson for his own good,
telling him that next time they might kill him.
But he refused to leave.
He went not even talk about the beating,
even when they offer to prosecute the man who had done it,
but he would do needle,
he would need a towel nor depart.
And then all of a sudden the whole thing's theme to blow away like an evil when
it was as though the time realize at last the he would be a part of his life
until he died and that they might as well they come reconcile.
So this is the crucial difference story that Faulkner is taling about southern
history is that the malice of your neighbors is the starting point.
It is not the end point.
Um,
it would be too easy or too much of a cliche to say that these people are just
better at it.
Um,
and they're going to post the Q.
Anyone who was not on the same line,
it will be much too simple to say that.
So this is the very important variations that men are not mass.
They fully,
they let the put it within high tops powered to report on them and the
timeliness in fact ran into prosecute those men.
Um,
so in fact the legal,
you know,
there's the legal action it's about to get started.
Um,
and certainly those actionable violence,
but just as the,
those people who who will be eating high tower put within his power to report on
him,
he refuses to use that power that they have put into his hands.
Right?
So this is a strange kind of symmetry.
This is the,
for me,
this is the most,
um,
interesting and compelling kind of reciprocity that you put yourselves in the
power of someone that you hate and you don't use the power,
the dose whom you hate or those who hate you have put bested in your hands.
Um,
is very given the fact that there's so much violence going on,
there's actually an incredibly delicate ethical gesture,
um,
on both the cost.
And I would say that this is,
um,
you know,
I don't know how,
I mean maybe this is two years Utopian,
I'm just reporting to you.
This is what will I think probably is doing,
um,
that this is the way that he would like to tell the story in this,
this,
the way that he hopes that human beings would conduct themselves under those
circumstances.
I should also point out that actually there's a in there in the book that I
mentioned earlier,
Labor,
um,
there's actually a strong argument in favor of ethical violence.
There's sometimes we just can help to environments to someone,
um,
but how to be ethical about that.
So for me,
this actually is an instance of ethical,
I mean qualified,
highly qualified,
but nonetheless ethical violence.
Um,
and I think it's because of that because there's actually,
this is violence within limits.
Um,
it is wireless that they has a degree of lawfulness to it in the sense that the
law is going to pros prosecuted them and those perpetrators actually have put
themselves under the jurisdiction of the law.
Um,
there's a degree of lawfulness to that kind of violence is because of that,
that I think that height,
how actually has this to say about his neighbors.
Hightower said they are good people.
They must believe what they must believe,
especially as it was I who was one who was at one time,
both master and servant of the believing.
And so it is not for me to outrage the believing no for baron bunch to say that
they arrived because all that NMN can hope for is to be permitted to live
quietly among his fellows.
So this is one kind of idea is that you can really change the way people,
what people believe about you.
You know,
they have,
they can have all kinds of wrong believes about you.
There's no way you can change those beliefs.
There's no way you can change how some other people feel about you.
Feeling is not something that you can dictate.
And other people,
if they haven't or hate you,
there's nothing you can do about that.
So that is a very um,
tough minded evaluation of the primacy of certain kinds of sentiment or not
really.
They that do not make for harmonious relations among human beings and hatred is
a very powerful reality for Faulkner.
So,
you know,
you just have to live with that,
but some people just don't like you all that much.
Um,
and given the fact that how can you still manage to live quietly and peacefully
among people who don't like you are that much.
That is the ethical challenge for hotel.
So all of this suggests that for him for now at this moment and pick 75 tower,
um,
is the ways of a certain kind of ethical norm and Faulkner and it's not
surprising that his name is Hai towel,
you know,
it's almost kind of to a very elevated,
very high calm,
maybe impossibly high kind of ethical norm.
Very few of us actually,
it can behave as he does at this moment.
Um,
but I think that we should also be aware that hide her actually doesn't occupy
that Moro height of the time.
Just as the narrative feel is quite often a few of have often there nothing can
fully occupied that feel.
Moral elevation is also a place where you can have full command all the time.
So this is a sudden different image of hightower from the town's point of view.
People who don't like him all that much,
what they think about how to tackle,
but the towels that the high tower that if hightower,
and this is not talking about his black cook anymore,
we're not talking about the violence.
Uh,
we're talking about something else that is also quite two other things about
hotel.
One is that he seems completely fixated on the civil war.
He seems completely fixated on his grandfather's death during the civil war,
the hoses galloping.
That is the reality for him.
And the other,
his wife is going crazy,
um,
in that marriage and he doesn't seem to be able to do anything about it.
So this is the town's commentary on those two other aspects of high towers live.
And you can see why he doesn't have full command of the,
you know,
ethical elevation that we've just seen him in.
Um,
but the town said that if hightower had just been a more dependable kind of men,
the condom man and minister should be instead of being born about 30 years after
the only day he seemed to have ever lived in the day when his grandfather was
shot from the galloping horse,
should have been all to the wife,
but he was not.
And the neighbor is with hero weeping in the parsonage in the afternoons or late
at night and the neighbors knowing that the husband would not know what to do
about it because he did not know what was wrong.
So all of a sudden the neighbors have been transformed from the perpetrators
perpetrators of violence to an independent voice of Judgment on high tower and
on the marriage.
Um,
they've functioning more like a great chorus in the sense that they have some
knowledge about the marriage that is deny to hide how himself.
Um,
and so we should not forget for a minute then a man who has so much such a
delicate ethical understanding of a southern kind of situation,
having to do with violence that is done to himself can be completely blind.
Um,
and,
and now the situation when it would have been good for him to have been just a
little more sensitive,
right?
So there's an Oh,
lack of sensitivity,
um,
in high tower that qualifies his claim to that ethical height that would say no,
it doesn't,
it's a totally different issue.
It doesn't take away from the,
the beading doesn't take away from the clan action,
but it does suggest that high tower is a divided figured.
Um,
and he doesn't speak for Faulkner all the time.
That Foglight is actually using his neighbors sometimes to pass judgment on him
just as he is a dispensive judgment on others.
Um,
so this is the neighbors in a different light and,
but there's yet another twist.
So fun.
It doesn't stop.
I mean this is a constant,
um,
switching back and forth,
the swing of the pendulum from the right being on the Labor side too,
right?
Being on hightower aside,
injury being done to hotel.
So this is neighbors and um,
yet another light within two days,
this is a little bit later,
the hightower was trying to deliver a black baby,
baby dies.
Um,
and within two days,
rumors were going around town.
Within two days there were those who said the child was high towers and that he
had let her die deliberately.
But Byron believe that even the ones who said this did not believe it.
He believed that the town had had the habit of saying things about the disgrace
minster,
which they did not believe themselves.
So this is yet another interesting portrait of how people behave as a
collectivity.
That as a collectivity,
we tend to say things that we do not actually ourselves individually believe it.
This is the nature quite often,
um,
of rumors of,
you know,
uh,
just kind of a standardized,
statements about certain situation,
um,
that you just repeat a certain line.
This is the nature of align that is fair to all of us and that we would mount
without thinking about it.
Um,
and all of us do it,
you know,
is not just,
it is not just people living in a small town always tend to say some things that
we're having nationally,
personally thought about.
Um,
including damage,
damaging things that we can say about someone like having a child and allowing
the child that,
so this is the nature of rumor and barons insight.
Um,
and he knows these people very well is that in one sense it is speech.
That's themes who through that actually doesn't have personal malice in it.
So we have to be very careful to distinguish than hurtful speech can certainly
inflict injury on the person that that speech is about.
It can inflict injury,
but something can inflate injury without having a lot of personal malice in it.
And that is the crucial distinction that Byron was us to make.
So we can see that constantly things are switching back and forth.
Right?
So we've been talking about,
this is,
uh,
Tuesday,
you know,
the protagonists and supporting has constant switch,
background,
foreground,
dark and light light in August dark.
How's the other title for the novel kind and unkind neighbors,
dramatic narrative versus in dramatic narrative.
But the of all this is coming to a head in the switch between Lena Grove and
Joel Christmas.
And this is a very interesting,
uh,
narrative innovation on the part of the pile of partner.
Um,
we've seen in the sound of the fury that it is a four section novel,
right?
And as I lay dying many,
many,
too many to count sections,
complete a split into tiny low narratives.
Um,
and in this,
uh,
novel,
um,
it's really to the story of two people who are strangers to each other.
Um,
you know,
it's a really huge challenge how you could tell a story about two people who
have no connection to each other,
uh,
but make the two stories one novel.
So we'll see how that is played out in weather.
Faulkner is completely successful in mechanic.
Those two,
um,
turning these two into a single story.
Uh,
but today we'll look at part of what he's trying to do,
I think,
and look at the contrasting functions,
um,
of being a growth and Joe Christmas and there's novel.
Um,
obviously we know that one is a positive catalyst for the community.
are the good about our community come out.
Uh,
when we see Lena Rove in action and all the bad things about Joe Christmas,
about the community come out when we see,
uh,
Joe Christmases podocytes are,
one's a positive,
Carlos the and negative calories,
but where there's artists don't you and all this seems to be pushing them to be
on opposite and,
uh,
of the narratives spectrum quite often partner also,
ah,
contrives to make them meet as well.
So it's a very interesting and kinship outweighed between the two of them,
even though they seem so different.
So we'll talk about the linguistic can share and also the fact that both of them
seem to be passive receptacles for when is coming to them.
So first,
uh,
when,
I think you know this,
but just one repeated from Lena,
this is the story.
Folks have been kind of been right time.
It is a very monotonous storage.
This is,
and in that sense she's not a very great character to another completely helpful
character to partner because she only knows one thing.
Um,
and the story never changes.
so it's,
it,
he really has two interviews,
the kind of a counterpoint to Lena,
um,
whose very name or really precipitate a negative response from the people who
are finding out I'm here learning about his name for the first time.
So there's two of form.
And um,
his hat,
there's the Joe Christmas was just getting a job from his people.
His name is Juan ones that Christmas you see a foreigner.
Did you ever hear of a white man named Christmas performance that I've never
heard of.
Nobody at our name it,
the other one set.
So just to have the name Christmas and you know,
I can't really think of a name that is less neutral,
less innocuous than the name Christmas.
Um,
but even for us,
I think to hear someone call Christmas,
you know,
there'll be kind of a strange response from those of us.
And sure enough,
there's a strange response from these two people.
Um,
so in realize that,
that in fact that we're not entirely immune from that.
Um,
you know,
it's not as though the world of farmer is creating this kind of slightly apart
from our world anyways.
We of that well,
um,
but we're certainly seeing an extreme reaction,
uh,
from these two people.
All of a sudden it becomes,
nobody here ever thought of him as being a foreign and something has got to be
four.
They do worse than that in foreigners.
Don't have a name like Christmas.
So maybe he's nonhuman.
Um,
not quite that,
but then he suddenly is in a unclassifiable,
uh,
but negatively unclassifiable category.
Um,
so less and the wrestlers story based on the consequences in many ways of having
a name like Christmas.
Um,
but for now I want to actually to not,
not to go there yet,
but to,
um,
talk about a very strange kind of kinship,
betrayed Lena and Joe who otherwise seem so different,
um,
is a completely counter intuitive kinship like thing is also white deliberate.
So let's just go back to this passage that we've talked about last time about
leanness,
peaceful journey behind her.
The four weeks,
the evocation of far is a peaceful corridor,
pays with unflagging and 12 who faith and people with Kai and nameless faces and
voices is the nature of um,
lean as journey.
And oddly enough,
the same kind of language is used again,
a very different moment in the story for Joe Christmas when it's actually just
about ready to do the killing.
Maybe I've done it,
maybe I've already done it.
He thought maybe it is no longer now waiting to be done.
It seemed to him to hear cause theory Yellow Day opening peacefully on before
him,
like a corridor and arrest into a still carers curo without urgency.
It's seemed to him that as he sat there,
the Yellow Day contemplated him droughts away like a prong and Solomon yellow
cab,
he will not move apparently arrested and how the Imobile by single word,
which had perhaps not yet impacted is holy and suspended in quiet and Sunday
space.
So that hanging motionless and without physical weight seem to wash the slow
flowing of time.
Believe him,
it is exactly one color.
Just put Lena right in there and they were better description of what journey.
Um,
so as I hope that it makes no sense to you who farm they would want to use this,
um,
for Joe Christmas right before the lower the violence.
Um,
I think that is,
is it is,
um,
is is something that cries out to be interpreted as reader.
You know,
why there should be the doer duplication,
um,
of the ones that are appropriate language for Lena into this completely
inappropriate and counter to counter intuitive contacts.
Um,
but all we can say is that this is quite heavy handed,
a attempt on [inaudible] part to generate a linguistic kinship between the two
of them.
Um,
let's look at another incidence and if we see a little bit,
um,
in the use of Germans in talking about this moment of impending instant pen
violence when he was house expanded but very peaceful.
Um,
and so this is the,
the use of Germans.
And we've seen that in Lena as well,
that fall within my hearing before I seeing,
I will be writing within the hearing of Lucas Bush before he seen we're here the
wagon,
but he will know so that we won who they are,
this hearing before is seen and then he will see me and he will be excited.
And so that we are too within the scene before he is remembering completely
highly conspicuous use of the journey.
Um,
and this also a Paolo highly conspicuous use of the journal for Joel Christmas.
And knowing not waving remembers a thousand savage and on the streets the same
use German but in a completely different context and completely different thing
matters.
Um,
so we really have to think low more about why it is even though the two of them
standing polar opposites that father nonetheless sees and is emphatic about the
cancer between the two of them.
So,
um,
maybe one way to think about this,
is to once again in this to,
um,
think about,
the relation between an individual and a collectivity or at least various
representatives of that collectivity.
Um,
and we've Leanor we've seen that,
um,
she really is a passive receptacles for all the southern hospitality and this
coming to her.
Um,
and maybe that's why she's really not that interesting on her own,
that it really takes action from other people too vast her narrative with any
kind of action that are left to their own devices.
There will be no story to tell really.
Um,
and so she's the passive receptacle in the sense that she's really the narrative
device by which a community gets to tell a story by which the action of a
community guests dramatize and gets register within a campus of a single
individual.
And I would say that that is also the narrative function of Joe Christmas as
well.
That in many ways,
even though he's probably more psychologically complex,
um,
they're meaner and it will be interested in and think about what kind of
psychology has,
in spite of the complexity of his psychology,
he has the similar narrative function in the sense that he is the vehicle by
which somebody else's actions.
Some of the analysis drama gets registers.
So he is the template on which someone else writes a dramatic narrative.
Um,
so this is his,
the continuation of that peaceful moment when he's about to do the killing.
He just sat there not moving until after awhile he heard the clock two miles
away,
strike 12.
Then he rose and move to what?
The house.
He didn't go fast.
He didn't even think even then something is going to happen.
Something is going to happen to me.
Is that some typical construction,
not I'm going to do something,
but something is going to happen to me.
So that I will actually kills on what is that,
that bizarre of transformation of what would it mean for Asian Miller of the
sentence.
Um,
so this is the,
even the most dramatic action that he's,
that he's responsible for his cast as something that's happening to him without
his volition almost.
Um,
and we're seeing that this is actually the logical combination of a pattern that
has been the dominant Palin all through his life.
So this goes back,
this moment goes back to when he was a kid,
um,
when he was watching,
when he was hiding in the getting toothpaste,
um,
in the closet and the Dietitian and getting sick from the toothpaste,
and then witnessing this completely bewildering thing that is going on between
the Dietitian and the man who was in the room.
Um,
and then all of a sudden he throws up in the Dietitian,
realizes that there's someone hiding in her closet.
So this is what happens when she's furious to know that you and the other man
that they,
the two of them are not alone in the room.
When the curtain flat back,
he did not look up when hands strapped him violently.
I would love to vomit.
He did not resist.
He hung from the hands.
Them looking with slack,
jawed and glassy idiocy into a face,
no longer smooth pain.
Goodway surrounded now by wild and disheveled hair,
who Smoove bands ones made him think of candy.
Eulo Rad.
The thin theories voice has to rad spine on a little negative acid.
Um,
so it's not been,
Joe has not really been in this orphanage with all this is happening.
He said he has not been,
uh,
nobody has up.
I mean if few of the suspected that something maybe low are the bias racial
composition,
uh,
but nobody actually up to this point,
at least nobody from the administration has called him,
um,
black.
Um,
and this at this moment,
uh,
when he is the unwilling involuntary,
unintentional and weighing witness to this scene that is unfolding and the
Dietitians room that that adjective is thrown at him and everything about the
description is that he's hanging from his hanging from the hands.
The dietitian,
um,
he's witnessing a phase that is completely transformed his,
the recipient of that,
his,
uh,
is coming at him almost complete passive at a,
on his side.
So that he really is the template on which the dietician is writing her own
theory and her own story.
One more example,
and this is his relation to his,
um,
to his adoptive father,
uh,
vacation.
Um,
we have various ways to pronounce that name.
I'm just going to bring on as a vacation.
You can finance it anyways you want.
Um,
then the boys do in his trousers collapsed about his feet,
his legs reviewed.
We need his wreath.
Should his stewards light and erect.
When the strap fell,
hit enough flinch,
no quiver passed over his face.
He was looking straight ahead with the rep calm expression like a mum in the
picture.
So once again,
this is not the kind of uncontrolled violence and is coming from the dietician,
but the very disciplined violence,
um,
that is coming from his own,
uh,
foster father that the father,
um,
but no matter what kind of violence,
it can be either out of control or are they totally control.
He is just there like a saint,
like a mum,
uh,
just totally calm,
um,
and seemingly untouched by that violence.
And that's part of the interesting fact about,
um,
about,
about Joe Christmas as well.
It's almost as if there's so the low,
um,
uh,
so,
so little contents to him,
although I hesitated to say that because that doesn't seem quite right either,
but whatever it is that is lacking in him,
there's no lashing out from him.
Um,
even the killing is not really old.
Didn't seem to be a tongue lashing out at the way he's treated.
Um,
so,
um,
there seems to be just kind of,
uh,
you know,
as blend a slate as possible.
Uh,
although it's probably not as blindness.
Lay this as,
as Lena is,
is a lot more context me,
but still relatively blank slate on which various succession of characters with
right on very,
very dramatic stories.
So this is the structure and that's why there's this very deep kinship between
the two of them,
even though they are totally different.